welcome to hannity and this is a fox
news alert the all-important gop senate
primary race in the commonwealth of
pennsylvania has yet to be called now
what six days after election day in fact
vote counting is still underway keep in
mind the state hasn't even begun the
recount process
every american should look at this and
realize this is unacceptable it's
unacceptable for the people of
pennsylvania it's unacceptable for every
candidate it's just unacceptable and
something that should be easily fixed
now major democracies all over the world
they're able to produce nationwide
results in a single night when they have
tens of millions of people voting but
apparently not pennsylvania now recently
france determined a winner in their
runoff presidential election in less
than 24 hours despite over 32 million
votes being cast last year canada
managed to confirm the results
countrywide during a single day in what
was a very close election and in 2016 it
took the united kingdom oh about a day
to get the final results there during
the brexit referendum despite 33.5
million votes cast in that election but
now it's taking the commonwealth of
pennsylvania what day six days maybe
weeks to count around a million votes in
a senate primary so what's happening
here how did we get to this point well
for starters the state's
widespread uh mail-in voting is a big
problem now in 2019 pennsylvania did
pass a new law allowing no excuse mail
in voting which by the way and
interestingly violates that state's
constitution constitution is very clear
on this rather than go through the
arduous process of having a
constitutional amendment which is harder
than passing a law
they took the easy way out which makes
the act itself unconstitutional
in fact the state's constitution
explicitly states that absentee voting
is
only allowed quote in the event that a
person's duties occupation or business
require them to be elsewhere or who on
the occurrence of any election are
unable to attend at their proper polling
places because of illness or physical
disability or who will not attend a
polling place because of the observance
of a religious holiday or who cannot
vote because of election day duties in
case in the case of a county employee
that's right there in the constitution
but now this recent bill allows any
voter to cast a ballot by mail for any
reason in the weeks leading up to the
election these ballots are accepted
until 8 pm on election day but cannot be
opened or counted until day of voting is
underway now so you end up with problems
like this and lag look at lancaster
county for one more than 21 000 mail-in
ballots could not be scanned because
they were printed with the wrong
identification code there is also
serious questions about mail-in ballots
with missing dates and signatures now we
are tonight in the middle of an
investigation on this program of a major
potential contradiction
from lawyers on this case we will have a
full report tomorrow and we will give
you all sides of that issue now no
matter how you look at this it's a train
wreck and by the way it can and it must
be fixed for example we saw what
happened in 2000 the presidential
election in florida an unmitigated
disaster but to the credit of the
sunshine state they resolved those
problems in part by counting absentee
votes as they arrive and addressing any
issues prior to election day now of
course as i have said many times for any
state to have true election integrity
you need several things you need
mandatory voter id laws signature
verification most states allow for
partisan observers to watch the vote
count from start to finish that should
be mandatory in every state in my view
you've got to have chain of custody
protections for ballots
and of course you should update your
voter rolls for every election and i'll
also add unlike new york city and other
places around the country
you need to be a citizen to be able to
vote and by the way the vote needs to be
counted in full in front of people from
every single party there up close not a
hundred feet away
not a thousand feet away now here we are
days and weeks of vote counting with
results seemingly changing overnight
does not inspire confidence or integrity
in the process to anyone at all
now let's be blunt um
if france can do it i think we can do it
too but there's not much time all the
states in this country we need to get it
right and get it right now tonight we
are just five months away from critical
midterm elections with the democrats now
in control in the house and senate and
the white house our country is falling
apart at the seams stagflation coming
recession spiking gas prices a
nationwide baby formula shortage
disaster at our southern border over a
million covert deaths and americans
still trapped in afghanistan if you're
counting like we are at state 282
since joe abandoned them behind enemy
lines but tonight joe biden he's in asia
where he told americans to suck it up
and deal with rising gas prices because
our country is going through an
incredible transition take a look for
yourself here's the situation
and when it comes to the gas prices
uh we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place that god willing
when it's over we'll be stronger and the
world will be stronger and less rely on
fossil fuels
when this is over
now joey actually said the quiet part
out loud apparently high gas prices are
the point now the suffering is
intentional is that what you're telling
us they want this country to to
transition into a socialist eco state
hell hole which would not be possible
with low energy costs of course energy
is the lifeblood of the world's economy
joe biden's policies artificially reduce
the world supply is it any shock that
demand remain constant and even increase
that the price goes up and we're all
paying the price the average family
because of biden inflation nearly six
thousand dollars a year if you drive a
car every day you're gonna pay about two
thousand dollars more for gasoline this
year we'll see how high the number goes
by the end of the year but remember this
it was only four years ago to the day
today four years ago today chuck schumer
posed in front of a gas station and then
berated then president trump for high
gas prices which at the time were under
three bucks a gallon now we're talking
about gas prices at six bucks a gallon
471 is the average today take a look
president trump's reckless decision to
pull out of the iran deal has led to
higher
oil prices
these higher oil prices are translating
directly to soaring gas prices
something we know disproportionately
hurts middle and lower income people
final price of gas under obama 2.36
current price for gas under trump 2.92
cents mr president you can't blame this
on president obama as you try to blame
everything on him
it's time for you to act
time for you to act well the climate
alarmist religious cult they're the ones
that are pushing joe biden to not drill
for oil not frack for gas we have gas
now poised as we told you last week jp
morgan predicting six dollars a gallon
average nationwide uh where's chucky now
uh 471 is the national average today
chuck now he's not out posing outside of
an exxon mobil station he's not
screaming and yelling about the plight
of the working men and women in this
country
or he's not lecturing or threatening
supreme court justices on the steps of
the supreme court it's almost as if he
doesn't really care about the middle
class and was only using them as a
political prop to of course bludgeon
donald trump chuck schumer is a big
reason why americans don't trust
politicians and then there's our
wonderful vice president kamala harris
while joe is busy in asia she's holding
down the fort right here at home and
it's going about as well as you might
expect take a look for yourself
you know when we talk about our children
i know for this group we all believe
that when we talk about the children of
the community
they are a children of the community
the community it's like an episode of uh
veep but whatever uh
if you like to watch these shows anyway
according to multiple polls joe and
kamala they're hitting record lows in
pretty much every poll according to a
new ap survey not only is biden's
approval at a new low he's also
hemorrhaging support among members of
his own base biden is losing support
dramatic support from the
african-american community hispanic
americans he's lost 40 percent of their
vote in one poll the youth vote is
losing a majority of voters believing
joe is both incompetent and distracted
but don't worry because the dumbest guy
in washington biden's chief of staff ron
klain thinks his boss is doing better
than ever in response to a new cbs poll
showing that nearly 70 percent of you
the american people think the economy is
bad and biden is slow to react ron
clayne is out there tweeting quote i
hate to spoil the rhetoric but this poll
shows the president's approval rating
moving up and solid public confidence on
the two biggest problems he inherited
covet and jobs uh really okay we ran out
of tests on your watch anyway remember
more people still blame joe joe by the
way last week's piac poll had him at 32
approval rating and that's among
everybody now unfortunately most people
simply cannot afford to live in ron
claims fantasy world in fact 64 of you
the american people because of biden
inflation the higher cost of every item
we buy in every store we go to
record high after record high after
record high gas prices 64 percent of
americans in this country are now living
paycheck to paycheck i've been there for
many years in my early adult life it's
not a fun place to be you have bills
being you know
being can be paid you have cars you got
to put gas in to run so you can get to
work groceries to buy meats getting more
expensive than ever spiking inflation
spiking gas prices coupled with a
looming recession it is devastating to
these americans but ron klain just
doesn't seem to understand hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else